I'm in Chris waters here for the final
hour of GameSpot's live stage show
extravaganza Palooza here from the stage
III said stage twice super OnPoint you
guys we've got an hour left and most of
that I was gonna be taken up by the
folks to my left and they are the
indicate folks Beth Sam founder of
IndieCade Coryell and John from White
Lotus Interactive I Ben we're gonna
start off talking about exactly what
indicate is before we get into your guys
game which is set up back there there
was someone with an oculus rift on I
don't even know what the game is it's
gonna be exciting we're gonna find out
about it together I just a reminder if
you guys have any questions tweet them
to me at CT waters on Twitter or use the
hashtag GameSpot III will check them out
but first Sam lets you have a lovely
shirt it says in decade beautiful color
gradiant indie games you know in the
past you know many years have risen in
have been an ascendancy yes
much to the delight and benefit of us
all it's been incredible to see the
industry diversify in this way and what
what role does IndieCade play in that
yeah so the quick answer that I always
like to give is that we are the Sun
Dance of video games oh right so we're
the place you go to find the interesting
and exciting innovative experimental and
artistic work that's being done in the
space indicates eight years old now and
they've been showing here at e3 for all
eight of those years and we have a
yearly festival in Culver City
California which happens in October in
October and I you guys I mean any
developers are far-flung all around the
world do you you fly some in do you have
some just sort of send their works in
how does that all work so we are we
actually run a submissions process every
year for the first half of the year from
late January through early June we get
submissions from developers all over the
world so that's the United States South
America Europe we've had submissions
from Egypt we get submissions from Korea
India Japan China so we really have a
pretty global reach um and our
submissions have been growing
astronomically year by year I'm not sure
where we'll get when submissions close
submissions close in three days but for
this year I'm guessing that will
a thousand when it's all said and done
yeah that is so cool and is that
something that you guys surface on your
website or is that like a festival how
does that content get out there to folks
well so we outreach through independent
development communities basically we've
been like I said going for seven years
seven years ago there were a lot fewer
indie danced we knew all of them and as
they because one of the great things
about the independent space is
developers really support each other a
lot of new developers come from being
pitched on doing any development by guys
who are already doing it in the space
and there's a lot of giving back so as
our community has sort of grown people
have just grown an awareness about the
events and we also do a lot of outreach
through schools some tons of schools now
offer programs in game design more and
more every year I wish that when I was
going to come right yeah yeah that'd be
cool but there's so many opportunities
out there now and indicators just one of
the places that yep indie developers can
get their stuff showcased speaking of
indie developers Coryell John thank you
guys for coming to this stage so you
guys have submitted through indicate
have submitted to indicate as well yeah
you know it was an interesting story we
were surprised about this whole event we
submitted NDK for the Culver City event
in in October and little did we know we
received an email to saying hey you're
coming to e3 and sure let's do it so
here we are that's a pretty awesome
surprise I'm really glad to have you
guys here so tell us about your game
what's it what's the title all right
Cory sure so our game is called zing the
land beyond it's a first-person puzzle
adventure for the PC and we also have it
on oculus rift very cool we see some
some gameplay sort of coming up now
we're not showing it in oculus mode cuz
it's that like still that weird
side-by-side kind of thing so we're
getting it in all its full full glory
here so it's a first-person puzzle
adventure and you know this is is this
right at the beginning I see we're sort
of getting some some prompts on how to
how to go about interacting we made it
this demo so that people could learn
kind of how to play
the game right away before we throw them
into it in the rift so all right so what
do you get is this one of these games
where you know puzzle games often have
mystery associated with them this is
something where you aren't giving the
player too much information and it's
about discovering what's going on here
or does the player have an idea of where
there are but where they are in this
game we decide to take out on a really
heavy topic so we decided to go into the
topic of death so in the game you
actually are it are pretty heavy so
unlike most games where you're trying to
avoid death you're actually already dead
so you don't have to worry about any of
that which is nice because in this case
when you die you don't actually have any
memories of who you were when you were
alive so you have to kind of figure out
well who who am i where am i what what
does it mean to be dead in a way so by
going through the many different
environments and solving different
puzzles you you can kind of understand
different things about different people
who you meet and and stories that you go
through and hopefully learn more about
yourself Sam did you see those signs
could you could you read those signs
they had before was it just me I mean it
seemed like it was not in English subway
I didn't want my e3 eyes to be so addled
all right so I hear we say it's it this
is a statue of Talal ik I mean that's a
that's an Aztec god yes so you guys have
been drawing from various mythologies in
your in your design here yes that's true
um all the different levels of Xing
actually are are based on different
mythologies and different places around
the world different time periods we have
cool architecture for the desert we kind
of have sort of a an Egyptian Persian
type theme going on but here in our
rainforest we have very Mayan Aztec
inspiration so cool all right so I chuck
in bananas around is that you know is
there some stuff you guys are sort of
laying out you know you're giving you're
giving clues in written form but I yeah
there's also environmental clues like
this gem pedestal and this mysterious
language and the moon door so is it in
terms of the player's interaction with
the world is it a lot about
experimentation yeah so we actually our
puzzle design we we've gone through a
lot of different iterations and we
initially had started doing puzzles that
were very akin to the old Miss series
it's a lot of code breaking a lot of
numbers and whatnot but we decided that
after after testing and doing a lot of
VR work we found that that was a
difficult thing for to ask of players
especially when they're completely
immersed into a brand new environment we
decided to start focusing on more
environmental based puzzles I kind of
became to be able to go to the Zelda
series na and and even portal to some
certain extent and going for that more
of okay so this button maybe raises this
ladder or if I press this button then I
cannot go up this elevator or different
things like that well how do I get to
this spot so that's the kind of gameplay
that we're going for and its really
responded well especially here at e3
while we're giving our demo I think
that's a really interesting thing about
VR as we start to see the oculus and the
Morpheus and sort of more developers
considering how to bring their games
into VR or to develop for VR I think
it's easy to think like oh it's just you
design your game but now you're wrapping
something around your face to see the
game instead of looking at a TV but from
a design perspective it's it offers
significantly different challenges
absolutely you know that and I like that
you said it from a design perspective
the technical challenges are a lot of
them are already solved and it's
actually relatively easy to get a game
into VR but for it to be a good game in
VR that's a whole another toll different
ball wax because you know this there's
funny things you trying to take for
granted when you're looking at a game as
a 3d game on a 2d screen that you you
don't get a sense of scale for example
and when we initially started developing
and we hadn't received our kit yet we we
tried you know playing our game and we
found out that you're just a little
munchkin and everything is huge enough
felt very very odd even though it looks
correct on a monitor it was completely
different in VR so you know not just to
mention that there's there's a whole
issue of controlling yourself making
sure you don't feel any out-of-body
experiences and and you know kind of
knowing where you're going and it's
definitely a challenge that we've
totally accepted and we're working with
it so Sam do you guys do panels at
indicate yeah we do we have a full
conference actually where we talking
about sort of what's going on in the
space I think that you should slot a
panel be our development mishaps and you
know turning out to be some little
really tiny person
you know motion sickness just standing
still like all that all this sort of
stuff that people discover I think it's
just fascinating to see the different
ways that you encounter new obstacles
with this kind of new format it's one of
the exciting things too about working in
the independent space in general is
everybody's really excited to jump on
new technology to experiment with it and
they try sort of everything but that
means you get a lot of really magical
failures fun magical failures that can
be the name of the panel all right so
it's turned night time during the course
of this during the short demo and
there's all sorts of glowing stuff and
are these sort of switches you've got
what all right now it's throwing me for
a loop I have no idea what's going on
the screen was the the we call these the
time of day powers so every different
level has a different power associated
that you're able to use as a player so
in this case you can change the time of
day from night to day or day to night
and different things happen in that in
puzzle wise story wise gameplay wise and
of course the environment changes
entirely so in this case there's a
puzzle where there's two different
pillars and one of them you can move at
nighttime and one you can move at
daytime so it's a simple boot you know
simple toggle that you have to do to
change the between the two but later on
there's there's puzzles there you have
to use several different powers at once
and you kind of go to different states
and it gets its pretty pretty
complicated with a lot of different bugs
you know you could be nighttime and
raining and snowing and all sorts of
different things that's a classic
compounding of mechanics and so integral
to any any puzzle game really Coryell
you're talking before about having sort
of you know in this jungle setting
having Aztec and Mayan inspiration but I
clearly the art here isn't just like
lifted from the textbooks or from the
Stella of you know Mesoamerican
civilizations there's a lot of original
art that you guys have created here yeah
definitely I mean we have our where you
first go in the game is actually so you
died right and so the first place you go
isn't one of these civilizations it's
it's actually this this area we've
called Zenith right it's like a point
above and but it but it's like this
almost magical kind of heavenly sort of
feeling place in a
we we did our own thing completely with
that I mean we almost went a little
sci-fi with all with all of that stuff
so um as far as our architecture in that
that that actually flows into the rest
of the game selling everything that you
interact with will either be that
feeling that that style I suppose
program or it will be the style of the
specific area you're in right on so you
know it this is a this is one sort of
area that the player explores and this
is you know as they discover you know
sort of the mystery of their life and
the mystery of what death is and where
they are you mentioned a little bit
before some of the other areas you'll go
towards in terms of the discoveries you
make are these are these are these
written are these audio that you're
hearing tell are you meeting people sort
of how does that can you give us a
glimpse as to how that plays out yeah so
the way the story is told
other than visually is that some it's
told through poetry that's scattered
throughout and there's different styles
of poetry and the styles of connect with
the lands and with the times
and like here we have the poetry for
Tillich so you know the skies they rise
right and what he's trying to explain
his he ends up trying to explain his
life and like what what he went through
and kind of how he died and once you
learn more and more about his story you
start learning more and more about your
story so all of the stories are actually
kind of intertwined they're kind of in
connected but you have to put the pieces
together literally and figuratively I
guess very cool so there's also a lot of
and that's a lot of ambient stuff
happening you know you've got the these
sort of floating moats you've got
flowers blooming and butterflies footing
here and there are there other
environments that aren't quite so lush
yeah one of my favorite environments
that we were designing is the volcano
level so to speak not of course is a
lava lava level of course we're trying
to do a new take on that of course and
I'm not gonna reveal any secrets there
is a volcano level and it is very cool
so but yeah the environments that we do
are we are going for a very peaceful
environments you know we
we want players to feel comfortable in
their their settings but we do want to
give that fantastic element and you know
there's definitely a lot of variety so
very neat Sam can you talk to us a
little bit about how you know these guys
told us how they they got the call and
the invite to come to e3 sort of suit
the interest
indicate sort of festival curation
process is already underway yeah so what
happens is as I said we take submissions
from January to three days from now
those are submitted through our website
and we have a very large jury and that
jury is made up in large part of former
developers who've shown in the events
okay and also journalists industry
experts academics people are related in
doing games work and we're already
during a bunch of those games and that
whole jury process is funneled tore and
focused on the October Festival but at
the October Festival and throughout the
year we do other showcases of games and
for those showcases myself then the jury
chairs and the festival chair Celia
Pearce who is another founder of the
event sort of go through and we make
subsets of the submitted games and we
think are appropriate so we have a
deadline it's like if you submit before
here you could be considered for e3 okay
and then we read all of those entries
and say this chunk of those entries
might be really good for e3 that gives
us like a hundred 120 games we play all
of those games and decide which 25 to 30
we're bringing here to e3 and contact
the developers we do that same process
for the other showcases so at the
festival itself in addition to the games
that are selected by the jury we do a
showcase of board games and showcase of
mobile games and those kinds of things
for that we pull out again a subset of
like a hundred games and huh would be
appropriate for that showcase and have
the judges or the curator consider those
and decide and here I thought I played a
lot of games I play games than almost
everyone so what can you give us a
little bit of an analysis of what you
what what was it about zing that struck
you that sort of made it good for e3 but
also that you know good for a showcase
what would you like so I can sort of
tell you a little bit of how the process
works when we're examining the entities
to look for what's appropriate for e3 or
for any showcase we want to
nice balance we want to highlight
indicates all that innovation
experimentation and artistry so we want
to find games you're gonna highlight
that but be attractive to the audience
that we're curating for III is a very
industry focused audience so we look for
stuff that plays to the industry but
also shares any cade when it comes to
zing that meant when we were looking
through entries I was deeply impressed
just at first glance by the screenshots
yeah my oculus and I was like this is a
beautiful looking game it's very
attractive maybe it's gonna also be good
and an IndieCade game and something we
can show then it goes into the pile of
stuff we consider right and then when we
played it me and a few other judges
played it looked at it and said you know
what in addition to being really
beautiful and mean something that's
gonna appeal to the media industry at e3
it also shares our values its innovating
in content its presenting a different
approach to what a game can be it's
about exploration and puzzles and sort
of philosophical reflection rather than
necessarily shooting somebody else or
something like that there's a distinct
lack of headshots so far in zing
although there's a lot of durian
wrangling which is very dangerous also
smelly alright so this isn't the only
indicated game you've brought along Sam
for us to show so we're gonna get a new
one on here to check out but Coryell and
john thank you guys so much for coming
on it's just about Zing's showing it off
do you guys have a plan for release for
when people can sort of get their hands
on it and try it out yeah definitely I
mean we're looking at releasing this
year so towards the end of the year look
for it I mean you can find us online
it's WWE the game.com that's Xin Jie yes
Xing with annex yeah very cool thank you
guys again so much so much folks we're
gonna take a quick break get some more
developers up on here and keep talking
awesome indie games stay with us